the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what sob ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video in today's video I want to talk
about the mother of dragons also known
as Daenerys Targaryen as most of you
know Daenerys has been one of the main
characters throughout the story and over
the years she has become a fan favorite
for many for the longest time her main
goal has been to take back the Iron
Throne for House Targaryen this is
something that she now believes she was
born to do now that her dragons are
extremely large and she has a massive
army behind her she does seem to be on
track to accomplish this dream of hers
when you actually look at her numbers
she almost appears to be unstoppable
however there are many fans that do not
believe the Narus Targaryen will survive
until the end of the story
in fact some would say that the show has
already foreshadowed her death many
times this has been one of the biggest
debates for quite some time
although the answer may seem clear to
some of you the million-dollar question
still remains is Daenerys Targaryen
destined to sit on the Iron Throne I
would like to think that one of the main
reasons why fans do not believe Daenerys
will survive is because of the vision
she had back in the second season of the
show now there are many different ways
you can interpret this scene but one of
the most common explanations is that for
shadows the death of Daenerys Targaryen
when she was at the house of the undying
Daenerys has a vision where she enters
of the Great Hall of the red keep as
soon as she walks inside we immediately
noticed the roof has suffered some
extensive damage some would say that
this could have been caused by a
wildfire but we have seen what wildfire
can do to a building when Cersei
Lannister had the Wildfire ignited under
the septa bail or it did not just damage
the roof it actually blew up the entire
building now when you look at the throne
room in Danny's vision you could see
that most of the building is still
intact the only section of the building
that seems to have been damaged is at
the top which means the attack most
likely came from above since we know
that Daenerys is not afraid to use her
dragons
there is a very good chance at least one
of them are responsible for what we see
in her vision we even get some more
evidence of this and one of brain Starks
visions when brain start goes inside of
the weirwood net not only does he see
the same thing - daenerys EES which is a
throne room covered in snow but he also
sees a dragon flying over the rooftops
of King's Landing now in my opinion I
have always felt that Daenerys would be
left with no choice but the burn King's
Landing that is mostly because I just
can't see Cersei ever standing down or
running away I think she will stay in
King's Landing and fight till the death
now the reason why fans think Danny's
vision for shadows her own death is
because of what happens next after
Daenerys looks at all the damage done to
the building she then begins to walk to
the iron throne which at this point is
completely covered in snow that could
also be another clue that Daenerys was
never meant to take the iron throne in
her lifetime because she was not the
next character in the line of succession
the snow falling on the iron throne
could be seen as symbolism for Jon Snow
being the true heir to the Seven
Kingdoms
as soon as Daenerys does come face to
face with the iron throne she sticks out
her hand that way she can finally touch
it but something happens before she does
when she is just inches away from
finally touching the iron throne she
stops after she hears the sound of her
dragons calling out for her now you have
to admit that this was very interesting
and you have to wonder if that does
foreshadow the ending of the series we
do know that it's only a matter of time
before Daenerys attacks King's Landing
but according to her vision she will
never take the Iron Throne what we see
happen next is also very interesting
when Daenerys begins to follow the cry
of her dragons we then enter her next
vision one minute she is standing inside
of the Great Hall then the next minute
she is walking out beyond the wall this
time she can see called Drogo's tent
when she enters this tent she finds her
dead husband called Drogo who just so
happens to be holding their dead child
almost as if both of them were waiting
for her now this is another vision that
can be interpreted in many ways but one
of the most common explanations is
Daenerys will die fighting the White
Walkers then she will finally be
reunited with her family the main reason
why many fans believe she will die
fighting the White Walkers is because of
the location a Khal Drogo's tent
obviously it is located out beyond the
wall in
Walker territory that could mean
Daenerys will be reunited with them
because she dies during the white Walker
evasion or it could just simply be
symbolizing winter as in Daenerys will
die during the winter I have to be
honest with all of you as much as I like
Daenerys Targaryen I cannot deny the
fact that these explanations do make a
lot of sense now this is not the only
reasons why fans believe Daenerys will
die next season another reason is
largely due to the likelihood that
Daenerys was impregnated by Jon Snow if
you were able to read between the lines
or if you have seen some of my other
videos then you would know they were
foreshadowing this over and over again
last season in fact there were so many
clues that I would actually be surprised
that Daenerys was not pregnant next
season I think there were at least five
different times last season we heard
characters discussing Danny's ability to
have children one thing we have heard
Daenerys say on a number of occasions is
Daenerys believes the Dragons will be
the only children she will ever have we
heard Daenerys and Tyrion talking about
this last season how do we ensure your
vision indoors after you break the wheel
how do we make sure it stays broken you
want to know who sits on the Iron Throne
after I'm dead
you say you can't have children but
there are other ways of choosing a
successor then later in the same episode
Danny said the same thing to John Snow
the dragons are my children they're the
only children 11 do you understand now
whether or not this was actually true is
up for debate however I believe that is
no longer the case the Dragons will not
be her only children if you remember
there is another phrase that we have
heard over and over again that is only
death will pay for life since Daenerys
looks at her dragons as if they are her
children then maybe vissarion's death
will pay for another life she might have
lost one of her dragons to the night
King but she may gain another child by
procreating with Jon Snow Sir Jorah
Mormont may have even foreshadowed this
when he and John were having a
conversation out beyond the wall it's
yours
it serve you well your children after
you
now one of the biggest clues was
actually when John and Daenerys were
having a conversation with one another
at the dragon pit during this scene
Daenerys once again says I can no longer
have children
this leads the John asking how she knows
Daenerys then says marry master was the
one who told her she can't have children
so this is when Jon Snow essentially
says the same thing that all of us have
been thinking um Danny did it ever occur
to you that she might not have been a
reliable source of information which
basically means that marry master was
full of [ __ ] so now that I have shown
you Daenerys is most likely pregnant let
me tell you why fans believe this means
she will die the answer is rather simple
although I will admit that it's not
exactly concrete evidence some of you
may not know this but the NARAS
Targaryen z-- mother actually died while
giving birth to Daenerys not only did
Danny's mother died during childbirth
but so did John snows this was actually
quite common back in those days so since
John and Danny's mothers both died
during childbirth then maybe the same
thing will happen at Danny since she is
having a child with John another thing
you have to keep in mind is what
happened during Danny's first pregnancy
as we all know she was able to survive
but there were some major complications
also that vision she had at the house of
the undying could have been another hint
as well
maybe it's the birth of a child that
reunites Daenerys with Khal Drogo
unfortunately for Daenerys these are not
the only reasons why fans believe she
will die next season according to legend
as well as Melisandre when darkness
gathers and the long night falls over
Westeros a legendary figure known as a
Zora high will be reborn again to fight
the darkness azor Ahai needed a forge a
hero's sword he labored for 30 days and
30 nights until it was done however when
he went to temperate in water the sword
broke he was not one to give up easily
so he started over the second time he
took 50 days and 50 nights to make the
sword even better than the first to
temper at this time he captured a lion
and he drove the sword into its heart
but once more the steel shattered the
third time with a heavy heart for he
knew beforehand what he must do to
finish the blade he worked for a hundred
days and nights
until it was finished this time he
called for his wife Nissa Nissa and he
asked her to bear her breasts he drove
his sword into her living heart her soul
combining with the steel of the sword
creating Lightbringer the red sword of
heroes now many fans believe Jon Snow is
actually azor Ahai reborn and in order
for him to create light bringer he will
need to stick his sword into Daenerys
Targaryen chest now I happen to believe
Melisandre is nice and Nisa
but I just thought I should mention that
because it is another reason why fans
believe Daenerys will die next season
there is one other reason I want to
mention before I end the video this next
one is rather simple and that is
Daenerys could always get betrayed by
someone very close to her as we all know
Daenerys has already shown some concern
when she was speaking with Varys on
Dragonstone and you really can't blame
her we all know Varys is one sneaky son
of a [ __ ] however Varys may not be the
only one Daenerys has to worry about
Danny's right-hand man Tyrion Lannister
has also shown some signs of a betrayal
no matter how much Tyrion and Cersei
hate each other at the end of the day
they are family and we have heard Tyrion
say that he loves his family very much
one of the main reasons Dany should be
concerned what Tyrion is because we do
not know everything Tyrion and Cersei
talked about when they met last season
say what you want about Cersei but she
is very clever at times and she knows
exactly how to manipulate members of her
own family when Tyrion met with Cersei
the scene and did after Tyrion realized
Cersei was pregnant but what else could
they have talked about before that
conversation came to an end
dead Tyrion Lannister offers something
to Cersei that could endanger Daenerys
Targaryen like I said before Daenerys
might have two large dragons and a very
big army marching behind her but she is
not unstoppable not only did bran show
us that dragons can be taken down but so
did the NIE king in a very big way
Daenerys might believe she was meant to
sit on the Iron Throne but a fur vision
is any sign of the future then Daenerys
may not live long enough to claim the
Seven Kingdoms for herself
I do like Daenerys Targaryen and I
happen to think that she would make a
great Queen for Westeros but I cannot
ignore the warning signs either let me
know what all of you think about the
fate of Daenerys
targaryen do you think she will finally
take back the Iron Throne for House
Targaryen next season or do you believe
she will die before the show comes to an
end leave your thoughts down below in
the comment section I want to thank
everyone for stopping by and watching
the video I appreciate that as always
and I also want to thank my patreon
supporters I hope you all have a great
day
I'll see you soon bye
you
[Music]